Paul WS Anderson does the Three
Musketeers in 3d the Three Musketeers
when I saw I was doing Three Musketeers
I was like but when I went to see the
movie I was like I'll give it a shot so
the three musketeers stars Milla
Jovovich Raghava vich however you say
your name but that shouldn't matter
since I said the phrase the three
musketeers stars Milla Jovovich why does
the movie about three dudes star her
because Paul WS Anderson directed it of
course and I think in his claws of
marriage he was like all right baby I
will put you in every movie I ever do
ever now we have this and it's a basic
story you know this young d'Artagnan KT
is a good swordsman he runs across the
three musketeers and now they got to
save France for the sake of God and
country and Christmas and stuff however
in the movie you see a few scenes where
Milla Jovovich is running jumping
flipping twirling sliding in slow motion
you're like why is this happening
because I'm telling you guys if Paul WS
Anderson directed a remake of
Schindler's List it would have her
running jumping flipping sliding
twirling in slow motion in an action
scene at a point in this movie and I set
it on my Twitter I was like this movie
is a cartoon it doesn't mean to be and
it totally is like all the villains are
like yeah us we are villains yes we
would take this country down with such
as airship from Final Fantasy 6 yes when
you war-machines redress the balance
they're all cartoon villains Christoph
Waltz is in it
I was sad that he was in it dude you got
an Oscar it you don't need to take these
jobs oh we got Porthos Athos and Aramis
also the three musketeers could have
fooled me they could have been Incan
blinking and Doc point is they didn't
feel like the three musketeers and they
could have been anything in anyone
played by anyone or anything and then to
press the out of me is an Alexander
Dumas lassic in the end it was turned
into some cheap 3d action movie for the
sake of doing 3d for the sake of making
money with hollow characters with a plot
that's just everywhere at the end they
have a showdown with Setzer's airship
from Final Fantasy 6 and that's kind of
cool but even then is for the sake of
throwing explosion on the screen but you
take it you you accept it cuz you're
like I'll take anything at this point
gave me the table scraps I didn't get
any of the romances in the movie I
didn't buy any of it the character
relations sucked it's like people keep
remaking Three Musketeers movies and
they're like alright let's throw more
crap on there alright we did the Kiefer
Sutherland one alright now we're gonna
do it again alright let's have someone
put hunk on choreography martial arts in
it Oh people don't like that
that's fine let's do Paul WS Anderson 3d
Milla Jovovich sliding on the floor
explosions everywhere it's dude it's fun
stop I'm just saying just give us a good
movie more crap you throw on the screen
for the sake of throwing crap on the
screen just irritates us it's like this
three musketeers movie is for Alexander
Dumas stories what Stephen Sommers GI
Joe was too 80s cartoons it is what it's
like I was watching it like this is
about as good as GI Joe I really went
into this movie giving Paul WS Anderson
a chance I really did in the end I'm
gonna show no mercy here for what the
three musketeers story should be to what
I actually just saw the three musketeers
is so what is your least
favorite Paul WS Anderson movie and if
you really want to venture out there
what's your most favorite I actually
have a most favorite I like Mortal
Kombat the first one for what it was I
thought it was cool whatever it may be
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more